[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson you're a personal astrophysicist
and today we're going to feature an
exclusive
conversation with a fellow
astrophysicist of mine
well we'll introduce him in just a
moment but let me get chuck out of the
way here check hey
yes get sucked out of the way no no
sorry i didn't how many times have i
heard that
i didn't mean it that way now i just
feel like i'm at
thanksgiving dinner
it just came out that way i got it
yeah all right so who we have with us
today is
i think i pronounced that right oh you
say
did i get that right hakeem everywhere
but in nigeria
that means i didn't get it right well
because the name is a statement
they demand it be stated like a
statement
oh you got to get in it okay let me hear
you say the whole name go yeah
oh hakeem
so you got to get in it yeah
they're nigeria only they they
they right all right all right they
don't care in wakanda
they don't care wakanda no it's yeah
they speak english in wakanda apparently
right yes
so you are a fellow astrophysicist and i
don't think we've met before
so uh that's actually a good sign that
means
um that means there are enough black
people who do astrophysics
that it's possible that two of them
don't know each other might have never
met
right okay well well well it turns out
that very briefly in 2002
at the american astronomical society
meeting we did meet
i was standing in an empty poster hall
monitoring the snap posters the
supernova acceleration probe
right which okay kmw first which is now
named after a brilliant woman uh and so
what happens is you walk up
and i'm like who is this black
astrologer this is i don't know and i
turned and looked around
and saw your badge and i just you know i
was looking at who are the other black
astrophysicists in the world
and i just discovered it i'm like oh
neil tyson and you're like
hi how are you
[Laughter]
i was fresh back from silicon valley i
kid you not no my first stop
okay all right okay so we did our world
line
okay so here's the thing that's right um
you met neal he just
has never met you
that's right that's right until now
all right so we got this so hakeem you
came out with a book a book let me get
the title straight here a quantum
life yeah you don't waste any time just
putting it right out
quantum life uh my unlikely journey from
the street
to the stars we'll get to that in a
minute but just want to get the rest of
your resume out here so we've got you as
uh an affiliated professor at george
mason university
is that right okay and thank you george
mason
president-elect of the national society
of black physicists
right and you used to uh be a space
education lead at
nasa and a chief science officer at
discovery communications
this is like not only discovery channel
but like 10 other channels that they
control probably other stuff too is that
right
well mostly focus those three focus
on science channel discovery and animal
planet we're sort of the science
uh realm of discovery communication
gotcha so if they got any science wrong
they'd
send the letters to you absolutely
absolutely
and but what intrigues me here is you're
also an inventor
and you've got 11 patents wow
11 patents what's your favorite
invention that you have made
you know what it's the one that i can
brag and say it's in all your chips
and it's not because it's that amazing
it's guacamole is in my chicken
not those chips thanks for inventing
guacamole i love it
but you know i worked at a large silicon
valley company that puts chips in all
your computers so if you develop a
technology
but basically my work um has made it
more efficient
and also helped with moore's law to keep
progressing oh cool
okay all right all right so so this is
part of your i mean i'm calling you an
astrophysicist but as you list the rest
of the stuff you've done
that gets us back to the subtitle of
your book my
unlikely journey from this street to the
stars
now now here's what i want to know uh is
this book
one of these i was a poor black child
is it one of those kind of stories is
that what's happening in here
man it is not it really isn't
yeah it isn't because my story is so
unique and it's so epic
that the reason why i wrote the book but
we'll decide whether it's epic
don't you be putting that on your own
stuff we'll be the judge that's okay
they told me you know i'm here
discovering and everybody keeps telling
me
oh man you got to write a book you got
to write a book because my life story is
so crazy you know how you meet somebody
and you throw out something you're like
holy crap what what haven't you done
what haven't you been through
right that was my life and so and you
actually obeyed them and decided to
write this up okay
all right so okay so so
i got to tell you the truth so i you
know lindsay sent me a copy of the book
lindsay one of our producers yes one of
our senior producers yeah
a couple nights ago and i
only had time for that night to read it
that because i knew what my schedule was
and i got through about uh at this about
250 275 pages
of the book uh and that's how good it
was i was reading it as homework
because i just wanted to be prepared but
i ended up
reading it for enjoyment which is why i
read 275 pages
in one sitting okay now lindsay didn't
send me the book so you should run the
damn interview
i know she did it
all right i'll send you through it i
will no i will fumble through this
and then chuck you come in and make it
better as i mess it up
okay no worries so so tell me so so
so where are you born that's right so i
lived in some
like historic communities i was born in
new orleans
and my home community is new orleans
east my father is from rural mississippi
so i spent half of my
you know pre-18 life there but also i
have a foothold
in south central los angeles man
where he has a bunch of cousins who are
actually
uh crips or were they the bloods oh geez
no they were crips
the crips yeah they were og banks and
you know
murders and went to prison for a couple
of decades and these are people you hung
out with
absolutely yeah man i've hung out with
everybody like
you know and that's the thing about uh
the current life
uh you know the current moment because
in science we have this sort of conflict
you know on the one hand if somebody
makes a mistake let's cancel them but on
the other hand
yo let's go into the prisons let's deal
with the um
you know the people that are
incarcerated and help them up through
education and science
so you know i believe in redemption and
because of so many people in my life
i've seen well i'm gonna push back on
you hakeem just a little bit
i don't i don't think that your story
was one of redemption
either not mine no not here he's talking
about the other people oh okay
i didn't even read the book and i knew
that chuck well listen
i never said i was smart just because i
could read 275 pages in a night
okay it just means i could read
they're little pages okay so what you
say what you're saying is
not to put words in your mouth but what
you're i think what you're saying is
your environment and the people and the
company you kept
was quite an exposure quite a baptism
into the
challenges of inner city life and the
life of poverty yeah
absolutely you know look everybody's
ready to beat you up
including your own family my family
happened to have
an entrepreneurial spirit so
nice uh and and very highly competitive
so i got into that life at the age of
nine
very seriously and it was something that
i was drawn to
i was with that life which life your
tournament i call it my dark side right
your dark life and cry it was like oh
gotcha gotcha gotcha
right that's the whole thing about it
that's what's quantum about it right you
have this
state of uh superposition between
these two two quantum states i get it
two quantum states and i'm
existing in both of them simultaneously
nerd
and gangster right gang's the nerd okay
but you're a black nerd so that makes
you a blurred
just to be clear okay just to be clear
all right so tell
tell us about how is it that you
kept your compass direction
throughout the crime the violence the
muggings the
you know how does it yeah because most
people don't and there's probably still
in jail in prison
yeah yeah because i didn't want to stay
that way right and
for me it was very simple tomorrow i
want to live indoors and eat
right and so when i was finishing high
school i'm like oh what do i do oh the
military
so i joined the military then i get out
of the military and at that point i'm
aimless
and some friends convinced me to go to
college so now in college you know you
have your dorm
paid for by your your financial plan
which for me you know one of the things
people been talking to me about all my
life is this free education we get
that missed me somehow so with my
student loans
i was able to pay for my tuition housing
food but then college is coming to an
end and i had no idea what to do
and luckily a woman named cynthia
mcintyre claude pooh and a
coot-box showed up on campus and said
hey we have this
thing we're starting called the national
conference of black physics students so
let me tell you why
uh how you can become a physicist which
i really didn't see
as my career i became a physics major
because physics was
is what was easy to me and the reason
why it was easy is because i fell in
love with albert einstein when i was 10
years old
and just studied it but even before that
i fell in love with logic problems
right and and so i would solve all these
logic problems so even though i was like
grossly undereducated by the time i
graduated high school
i was passionate about the universe and
i had taught myself a lot of physics
without knowing so you were incompletely
educated you still had passion
for learning which is a very important
thing and and i think you're being a
little humble because
you are clearly an auto died and have
been your entire life
and that means i don't even know what
that means what is that what is an auto
die that is that a good thing or a bad
thing did you use a customer did you
just
no it means that you're able to teach
yourself you are so
you are self didactic you tell yourself
so so instead of saying he's self-taught
you call him an autodidact
yes yes okay so i must be a biologist
i don't know what to help chuck okay
but seriously i think the other thing
that
is a a bit under looked
i mean um under appreciated and i say
this not just to you but to
everyone listening what people see in
you
is the case and you should you know
people
often look at you and see something
and because you are in your current
situation
you can't see it and so
throughout your life according to your
book there were always people who were
like
hey man you should
hey man you should and there's a spark
of something in there right the reason
why they do that is because
they see it and now look where you are
they saw it and it was
there but here's the thing you didn't go
quite far enough in the book
okay he became a serial murderer and
then no
no i did not but that's what people saw
so i'll give you a funny a story from
the book so in 2013 i was at uc berkeley
doing summer research and i ran into a
graduate student friend and he said
hakeem
remember that story you told me in grad
school and i kind of forgotten about it
so basically what had happened is
because of my life of crime and the way
i was living wrong
i dropped out of college okay and i
didn't want to live the life i was
living
anymore and to be honest i continued
after this relapse and relapse type
thing
um so i got a job
and the only job i can get was as a
janitor at a nearby hotel
i was making four dollars an hour
getting something like 20 some odd bucks
a week i got a small apartment deep in
the hood
and i don't even have enough money to
eat so the way i eat
most days is i eat people's leftovers
from room service
that's how i was eating then i get my
big break or so i think
and that is the bellhop hotel gets fired
right and i'm thinking yeah i get a
hundred dollars in tips in a day
but guess what according to the hotel i
was in bellhop material
right i wasn't front door material and
so my friend who i was speaking to in
2013 he said you know what to me that
story encapsulates what it's like
to be a black man in america because
they didn't realize that the guy
standing in front of them was a stanford
phd physicist
all they could see was the janitor right
but that is because uh they they were
trying to hire
a freaking bellhop so you also got to
consider the source
you know so i won't belabor the point
but i'm right hakeem
all right wait wait there's way more to
this story we got to take a break but
i came i want to know what branch of the
service you you went to
how did you end up in stanford how did
you end up even
in college in the first place and so
i i don't want to jump ahead too fast
because i'm still in south central l.a
with you
right here in my in my own head so when
we come back more
of hakeem and let me get his last name
hakeem
coming up from the depths of the
uh of american poverty and crime
to be a leading astrophysicist when star
talk continues
we're back with an exclusive interview
with hakeem
ulusei who is a fellow astrophysicist
my first time really officially meeting
the guy
and apparently chuck got a copy of the
book before this interview because he
wrote a memoir
and chuck read the book and i don't i
haven't even seen the book so
chuck i think i should just go to you
know go have lunch now and you finish
the interview
no cause i'm hungry too so
okay so it's my a quantum life my
unlikely journey from the street to the
stars and
in a quanta are sort of states of
existence
of particles and if you apply that to
your life
um i came you told us in the first
segment that
you were this sort of street kid but you
were also this
nerd and the two generally don't have
bridges between them
and when you don't they're separate
quantum states but they coexist in the
same body
so it's a superposition of these two
quantum states if we're going to
run with the physics of it but so so at
what point did you say maybe i'll go to
the military
was that to to to try to bring some
order to your life and get a hot meal
every day
no just like many other things i had no
direction and someone came along and
said hey how about you try this
so what happened is at our high school
now let me tell you about my high school
i grew up in heidelberg high school in
jasper county
mississippi all black a mile and a half
down the road heidelberg academy
all white right and so we were all
told to go wait it can't have just been
a mile and a half down the road they
have to been like railroad tracks or
something or
freeway nothing nothing like that you
could actually just walk
from oh yeah it was just
they made it especially cruel
they were like we're not even going to
put any railroad tracks
you're not even across the tracks right
you're gonna be able to look right down
the street and see what you're missing
okay yeah yeah yeah
what was the question yeah no no sorry
sorry so just
how did how did you land in the armed
services and which branch was it
yeah so i was in the u.s navy so it was
a very lucky thing for me
what happened was we were all ushered
into the cafeteria and we were given the
armed services vocational aptitude
battery exam
and i would kill all standardized exams
everything but the math
and so so what happened was
a few weeks later i get called to the
principal's office which was not an
uncommon occurrence
but when i got there he blew me away
with what he said
he asked me he said what are you doing
after high school and i said
uh i'm gonna go to college and he goes
cause i knew that's what you're supposed
to do
and he said how are you gonna pay for it
and i said well
i'm a good musician i'm a good student
i'll get a scholarship
and he's like let me introduce you to
someone he takes me into his inner
office
and in there in this dress whites is
senior chief gage the navy recruiter
he stands up looks me in the eye puts
out his hand and goes hi
look the most i can offer you was 20 000
a year
this is 1983 right when he said that
number
my mother's voice went off in my head
because i i remember her
bragging about my brother-in-law earning
fifteen thousand dollars one year
and this guy just offered me twenty was
that twenty thousand dollars a year
after you get out for you then to spend
on college is that
no money i don't know this is be this is
full-time navy career
right right so i joined the neighborhood
i think that was going to be my career
forever
they were going to put him in the
nuclear program he was going to go nuke
yeah pass the nuke test but then my
recruiter was like dude you're so
amazing you know what i think i can get
you in the academy
but he had never done the process so it
was too late but he did find this
program
designed to take enlisted people and
convert them to officers
but it was people from backgrounds that
were undereducated so they gave you a
year
of education and they had two math
classes the regular math class and a
remedial math class
now we have a facebook group for all of
us that were in this boost
85 86 class they think it's hilarious
that they were in the regular class and
the astrophysicist to be was in a
remedial class
right but in that remedial class we were
taken from arithmetic through calculus
in one year
before arriving i never heard the word
calculus in my life i
did luckily i didn't get kicked out
until
i completed the algebra portion okay so
so just to recap
so this this standardized exam you took
you did really well on
all parts except the math part and you
did so poorly on the math
part but so well on the other part that
they said they brought you in the back
office
but then they put you in the remedial
math class is that did i
get that right it's similar ish to that
you you had to take
a placement exam and that's what landed
me in the in the remedial class
i got it okay all right so then you
became a fast study and this you pick it
up and then you go to the navy
and and what do they do with you in the
navy oh man so i start off in a nuclear
program then i transfer to this program
called boost
and it's run by the marines and man do
they kick do the marine
do marines kick your butt so i my
discipline level
so just to remind people the marines are
actually a branch of the navy in case
anybody
needed to remember that but also there
are two kinds of nukes
there's the nuclear submarines which is
just an energy source
and then they're nuclear weapons so
which of those were you
nuclear submarines in fact i had
befriended
a former nuclear submarine captain and i
would sit around with him talking about
his uh
he's retired and became an instructor at
boost and i would you know just love to
hear his war story so i thought i was
going to be the captain of my sub
someday wow so but then you had to
you couldn't serve because you had a
skin condition and you can't be
is that the deal absolutely so you know
how it is if you don't have health
health insurance you don't go to the
doctor
so i had this horrible skin condition my
entire life
and i got diagnosed for it
properly for the first time in the navy
and they were like oh
sorry you can't be in the navy with this
because it impacts your readiness it
really was horrific
i must say and i didn't get proper
treatment until
almost a decade later when i was in
graduate school wait wait so it's like a
some kind of psoriasis or something what
what
is an atomic government it's an
incredibly severe case of atopic
dermatitis
like have you seen me in my youth i i
scratched so much
i was hairless and i was several shades
darker for breaking all the melanocytes
or whatever they're called in my skin
uh yeah it was a it was a mess man and i
was in pain
100 of the time of course my torso yeah
wow okay so that's all right damn you
know you should write a book
okay so wait so over all this time
you're you're reading einstein and other
sort of fun physics and the bible's in
there too so how did the bible
show up in your life yeah well listen i
was in church every sunday you know
wherever we live we moved every year and
several times every year
right uh and several times in some years
and
everywhere we went my mother didn't care
what the denomination was we're always
in the black community for the most part
and you were going to church
um and you know being a little scholarly
dude
you know you know how it is i became
voracious with books
uh so when i was um in mississippi
my brother-in-law let me know that dude
you're not sitting around while
everybody else eight years of and older
going to work
at 12 years old you're going out there
you're hauling pulpwood in those woods
for my father and brothers
and if you don't know what holly pope
wood is you don't want to know
so okay it's it is crazy
hard work and for a child you know it's
criminal damn near
but um a few days out there my skin
erupts head to toe right and so
i'm left at home every day and i'm like
searching for reading material
and there's the big children's version
of the king james bible and the regular
version so i just spent day after day
sitting there
and i devoured the bible from cover to
cover and the next year i was the adult
sunday school teacher
okay okay
teaching adults teaching adults oh yeah
yeah so i started off with the kids and
then i moved up to teaching the adults
because you know i had so much insight
uh at that point and you know i you know
how it is when you're uh you have that
process of brain
it's one thing to have read the bible
and know what's in it it's another thing
to have digested it so that you can now
teach lessons to people in bible school
that's a whole other level right
yeah it is but it doesn't it happens
automatically right
you start making connections and you
start and for me no it doesn't happen
automatically it happened automatically
for you
just think about it i mean by the way
it's not unique to the bible just
because you got an a
in your physics class doesn't mean the
next day you can start teaching that
very same class
because teaching it requires some deeper
insights that enable you to communicate
what you just learned and it's not just
a recitation of a fact that just came
off the page
so that's right so all right so yeah
don't stop trying to think everyone is
as smart as you
human humans are dope i'm a human you're
a human
chuck's a human yeah
[Laughter]
but i do think neil is right in this
that people who are in your position
feel as though oh well everybody does
this and it's not really the case
you know and it's funny because i had a
teacher who
that was how he taught us he would say
all right so you think you got it and we
and when you said yes he would say now
teach it to me and that's how you
measure that that's how you got your
grades well here's the thing though
were you interested in that that helped
how about how did you think when you
were
interested in things because i would
come to you easier it would come easier
i agree absolutely and i was surrounded
by people like my good friend chris
morgan right he finished high school
he's been working a job ever since
didn't even consider going to college
right and in fact we were chatting and i
was like what are you doing after high
school
he was like nothing you know
it was like i thought okay supposed to
go to college or the military right
uh but look that dude was brilliant he
was kicking my ass we would play games
you know he was
chris was dragging me and i was
surrounded by brilliant people even now
and one of the worst things that happens
you go home and you want to hear the
wisdom of your homies but because you
got some fat
some fancy degree they're like oh i
can't talk to you man
i'm like nah man i need the wisdom
that's in your head too
right right right right in all walks of
life all work
you have some good friends because when
i go home and i see my friends i'm like
i want to hear nothing this dude
i've known you my whole life use a dumb
ass if i ever met one
well you know i do but listen now when i
started talking science i had this one
friend he'd always go
that he go with that stuff again like
they didn't want to hear that they
didn't want to hear the science
yeah right right well so what's this
about daydreaming and why
that was dangerous uh did you you day
dreamed a lot
as a kid i still do i still do man i
still do
i just daydreamed up four big bangs last
week
what do you mean by four big bangs
because we think of it as one big bang
right so to us physicists you know we
know that you know matter and all this
stuff is an illusion and we live in this
universal fields
so imagine you got something like
swimming pool of jello
right okay and you have several them
one's green one's blue one's red one's
yellow and you just merge them together
in one
right so that's like all these fields
merge together so we have
the inflaton field goes from this high
energy to low energy
boom gives all this money to space field
that's the first bang
space expands rapidly as a result
second bang but that rapid explosion of
space
causes it to fill with matter and energy
suddenly pow right
but it's equal amounts of matter and
antimatter
which annihilate boom fourth bank
okay chuck he's still on drugs
apparently
that's for banks come on now let's have
a look at the authorities now
but it's core the fair beyond field
right it sends its energy into the
electromagnetic field
it's like energy goes from infinite
field to space field to fairview on
field to
electromagnetic field and then what has
happened space stretches it out
right okay so so is this something you
daydream recently or when you were
younger last week
last week okay i've been i don't know
all right so when did you when what was
the transition between
uh physics and
astrophysics when you finally you know
when you find
sense finally descended upon you and you
realize the universe is cooler than
anything else
yeah so the thing about the universe
i've been attracted to it from day one
i've been attracted to nature
but i was also attracted to weirdness
right so
i learned you know my my friend told me
that hey you know if you're under 18
you can't be held to a contract so i
used to order those time life books
you know yeti the the you know bigfoot
all that kind of stuff
and you know i got into comics my
mississippi cousins introduced me to
marvel and dc comics and i loved it so
when i hit einstein and relativity i'm
like this is just like that stuff
like the miracles in the bible sci-fi
all that stuff
except it's real yeah exactly it's real
and then i was like i gotta learn this
so i started teaching myself relativity
at the age of ten and i just struggled
with it
and i didn't realize that i how well i
knew it until i won first place in
physics in the mississippi state science
fair
right and these professors started
coming at me and you know i didn't know
anything else about physics
but i knew i knew that um and so in
college
what ends up happening is i take my
first physics class realize this has to
be my major
and then i get accepted miraculously
though strategically
at stanford for graduate school and when
i talk to all the professors they have
one african-american professor
i wanted to do experimental astrophysics
astrophysics i felt
was where the natural world met
weirdness and
hoof let's do it yeah that's true i i
gotta give i gotta agree with that so
where did you go to college before
stanford
tougaloo college yeah tougaloo in
mississippi in mississippi that's right
i would say that was their loo is motto
right no i just made that up um we got
to take another break when we come back
i want to understand
hakeem uh what this obsession you had
growing up with compulsively counting
things uh and a little more
about your very unlikely quantum life on
star talk
we're back star talk i got checked nice
with you chuck
hey tweeting chuck nice comic and i got
my
a special exclusive guest for this
interview hakeem
and hakeem you're on social media
i am yes what do we call you how do we
find you on twitter
if you put hakeem olushi in twitter that
is my
handle there and no one else has that
twitter name
yes okay yeah o-l-u-s-e-y-i
again there's a facebook page as well i
presume there is i'm not there
as much i i suck in that way okay
no but i do have instagram and i have a
first initial middle initial hmo luchadi
h m o usai okay all right thanks for
that for
that info so uh we learned from your
profile that you you counted things as a
child
and i feel obsessively compulsively and
i still and
is that a good thing or a bad thing well
i wouldn't see a psychologist
because i thought it was a problem
because my eyes divert to count things
in the room around me
right and so if you're doing business
negotiations you should be looking the
person in the eye
are you counting like objects or any
kind of objects in this
category patterns like behind you there
is a picture frame
i like particular numbers like 10s and
20s so every frame
is an easy 20. so my mind will do it
over and over as i'm talking to you just
like i have been doing the entire time
we have been talking
so each inner corner is 2 4 the outer
corners are 6 8
the inner right pay attention to me what
to me i'll show you pay attention to me
well 40 16 18 20.
you just do it over and over and over
and over and over i just can't stop it i
don't know what's going on
yeah all right that is that's a little
weird that's a little bit oh you want to
hear even weirder
when i go up and down stairs not only do
i have to count them
i have to count them in such a way that
when i go down them
my left foot lands at the bottom and
lands on the number one
and when i go up them my right foot must
land at the top and land on the number
100
which means i have to guess what number
and what foot to start on at the
beginning of the stairs
and you'd be counting by fives or sevens
or tens i mean no no just
one just by once
you might not have a hundred steps
because ten sticks below below 20
i'm nailing it if it's ten stairs i got
it boom it's just i don't know what it
is about my mind it's like
oh it's up to a hundred is how you would
be engaging like
for example if i see 17 stairs or
whatever i have to start on my right
foot on the number 84
at the bottom and then go 85 86 788
that's when i get to the top
200 or 100 yeah yeah
so good at it it's nuts see we have that
in common
i have to land on a prime number which
is why i always take the elevator
okay so so hakeem you know do i
even dare share this with you so when i
was a kid
i thought of all the numbers that were
just living in my head
and i decided to write down every single
number
that had any meaning or significance to
me at one sitting
are you done yet no no at the time
just not forever but still thank you
forever so i wrote down every
zip code that had any meaning to me i
wrote down every phone number
seven digit phone number that had any
meaning every street address
every uh the digits of pi yeah i also
happen to know the fifth route of 100 to
12 decimal places that's down there
and so it's a whole page just filled
with numbers
and but i don't i didn't view that as
as compulsive it was just how many
numbers am i
carrying with me and is that necessary
i think it was more of a practical
exercise yeah and then i
stood stepped back and looked at it and
i said that's i think that's a lot of
numbers
but i i tried to make sure i it didn't
grow
so that i had room for other things in
my brain but but this number thing
there's some resonance there between us
i just thought i'd put that out there
you know there's even more i also had
other kind of superpowers like you named
that i no longer have
like rotary phones i used to just amaze
my family because i was like you dial
this number because i could just tell
from the sound of the phone
right or if a car pulled up in the yard
and it was a family member
that's so-and-so just from the sound of
the car right so the people around me
were like oh this kid is a freaking kid
absolutely and because my eyes are a
weird color when i moved mississippi
there were some several elderly people
that was like that boy have devil eyes
he's evil and they just
treated me like crap yeah what a shame
okay
so let me ask you both this is so weird
speaking of your childhood
all right so like in your book you have
these moments where
you look to the stars and it has
a profound effect on you where it causes
you
to go outside of yourself you know
and i know neil when he was a kid had
the same experiences
yeah in the planetarium i was nine years
old and the lights dimmed the stars came
out
and that's oh that's that's it i was
star
struck ever since and i go out into the
real sky when i finally saw a real sky
because i grew up in new york city and i
look up at the stars
and i just place them in the full
three-dimensionality of the universe
and and for my whole life to this day
anytime i'm alone out under the stars
but i have to be alone
if i'm alone i want to be abducted by
aliens i want a beam of light to come
down
and zap me back to some other planet and
i want to meet the aliens
oh you shouldn't do that i would have
made a call
is there something now with all of your
experience
exposure and knowledge of the universe
is there something now that gives you
that same
experience in your work
in your work or in your admiration of
the universe or
anything that puts you in that same
wonder of
i see the night sky in 3d oh my god
kind of out of body kind of like this
this is why i'm this is why i'm
here like is there something now that
happens
absolutely sometimes you have these
insights right that that aren't really
insights but just like oh that's really
interesting
so for me data does it and so the data
that did that for me a year ago
was a visualization created from sloan
digital sky survey data done by lawrence
berkley laboratory so we say things like
oh there's
two million or two trillion galaxies in
the observable universe and we show
these
slices of the universe but when you see
a 3d representation you can look around
the universe you see what the galaxies
are
but just to be clear when you project
the full 3d universe on paper you take
slices through it these are the slices
you're referring to
when you go to a full visual 3d
representation no longer are slices
necessary
right just want to clarify that yeah is
that the is that the baryon oscillating
stereo
coptics you've heard a lot of stuff
survey well no
no this is this is before that so this
is before that
yeah this is the this is the precursor
to that basically in a way
okay yes slowly disguise survey um but
so here's okay but this is not your
imagination it's not
in 3d printing it's actually a 3d but it
triggered my imagination because what do
we do we teach students
astronomy in order for them to
understand the universe we say well you
know
things like this analogies the universe
is the basic building block
of the galaxy is the basic building
block of the universe in much the same
way that the cell
is the basic building block of your body
and i thought to myself well you know
what let me take that
to a to the limit let me take that
seriously so what if i shrink myself
down
so small that the size of a human cell
in respect to me is like the size of a
galaxy
with respect to me now right so that's
like 20 orders of magnitude for the
nerves out there
so i did that and i was like what if i
then
study the universe from that perspective
so say i'm in an elephant and i'm like
oh
i see these types of galaxies they're
spirals they behave this way they're
structured this way
oh i see these they're ellipticals they
behave this way they orient themselves
this way
now let me do the same thing in my
analogy i'm an elephant oh i see a nerve
cell
these things behave this way they
distribute this way blood cells bone
cells muscle cells
do you have any freaking idea what an
elephant is
okay so what you're saying is
so okay so you you are um
who's the woman who drives the bus that
can go any size the magic school bus
you you you're on the magic school bus
at all times at all times at all times
wow that's pretty wild though man that's
a it's a great analogy i love it
yeah yeah yeah it's it's a change of
perspective it is
let me give you another change of
perspective right because us scientists
we always like to talk about like
how everything is just all space like oh
you know how long does it take a light
raid you know that you know that uh
visualization on the internet where
in real time we're going to travel
through it shows that this is the travel
of the beam of light yeah it's a
brilliant
a completely brilliant visualization i
tweeted it everybody's wondering oh so
someone shows the actual beam of an
actual beam of light well i mean the
video of a beam of light
moving from earth to the moon and it
takes about one and a half seconds so
you see it take one and a half seconds
then you see a beam of light from like
from the sun to the earth that takes
eight minutes and 20 seconds so you wait
there for the eight minutes
so and watch you say damn that light is
slow right
right yeah yeah
so so in your in your phd uh you
quote um ibm al haytham we spent a bit
of time on him in
cosmos so why don't you remind everybody
who he is
he is i i consider him the first uh
practitioner of the scientific method
he's the guy who showed
that the eye is a passive receptor it
does not send out a beam and bounce back
and when isaac newton your favorite
sciences i've heard my boy
if i if i have seen father than others
it's because i've stood on the shoulders
of giants
evan al hayden was one of the people he
was speaking of because his book of
optics as a scientific treatise in
history around the turn of the century
1000
just changed everything right so this is
in the golden age of islam
back between like hundred and eleven
hundred uh
a.d so so there's a quote here which is
it's the it's it's got it all in it you
will you allow me to read it if please
please okay
everyone loves to hear you okay so just
a reminder even al haytham
was a mathematician and astronomer and
and basically
credited with the first formulation of
the scientific method
which would take probably another 600
years to become
widespread use but he landed there first
and
if learning the truth is the scientist's
goal
then he must make himself an enemy of
all that he reads
he should also suspect himself so that
he may avoid
falling into either prejudice or
leniency
wow there in two sentences
is the fundamental seeds of the
scientific ones
yeah there you go and you see his and
his uh
statement about ptolemy is is amazing as
well
yeah for a man to imagine an arrangement
in the heavens does not make an
existence
okay no that's good yeah i like the
first one better very good
let me we got like a couple minutes left
here so
so so tell me you you were born james
plummer
jr that's right and now you now you
pulled the african card
so where did that come from and why you
know what so
the first thing the seeds of it started
when i read my very first novel which
happened to be the book roots
uh everybody was talking about it you
know i didn't have any love for
adult books at the age of nine right uh
and so i'm sitting around the farm bored
as i don't know what i'm like let me
give this thing a read
and i got stuck i mean i could not put
it down
but when he got captured that was the
first thing that just got me in the
heart when kunta kente got captured
i captured right uh then the second one
was the the the the
you've been wait wait and you've been a
a um
star trek next generation fan ever since
right i was thinking of him i didn't
know whether or not i should say so
okay remind us who played kunta kinte
lavar burton lavrar burton who when i
met him
was the one of the very few times i've
ever been start star struck
and he bought me my very first gen vodka
tonic
so wow okay all right
that's in 2015 in 2015. yeah okay
all right that's pretty cool man all
right so so keep going so now you're
you're
in in roots now so now what yeah so uh
then the thing that just kills me man is
when they forced him to change his name
right and so that just planted a seed in
my mind
right and so as i'm developing uh
you know believe it or not this really
isn't in the book but so what happens is
you know how you make these connections
by the time i'm out of the navy and i'm
in college i start making these
connections
about the society in which we live and
all the way it works against you know
the way it maintains the hierarchy the
social economic hierarchy we have right
yes
implicitly and explicitly and legally
and de facto and du jour there's a
hierarchy
so you know how you sit around your dorm
room listening to music
and other things so i would uh you know
start talking about this stuff
and the group of people grew and grew
and grew so we had to take it to the
dorm and everybody's like oh you're a
prophet and then these cats from the
nation of islam showed up and i was like
this is over
i am not doing this anymore it's gotten
too serious but you know i was just like
making all these connections you know of
what's going on but that did that just
to remind people the nation of islam is
the branch of
islam that is based in the united states
of america that's right medicine is
there any more description of that that
i have to give
well it's not really a branch of
standard islam it's sort of a new
religion
that was founded by elijah muhammad
where he completely
a coincident with malcolm okay yeah yeah
so go on mm-hmm
yeah so uh what was the question again
yeah sorry
your name changed how did that how did
that lead to your name change yeah so
when i get to stanford
right i feel like there are certain
things i need to know
um this is stanford a graduate school in
physics graduate school in physics right
yeah so i had this
buddy because i was you know what they
called afrocentric at the time who
always was encouraging me to read
certain literature and i never would
when i got to stanford i was like
blackness help where are you
and then you know i found it in the
library and so i started defying just
devouring and i had certain questions in
my head for one thing i want to know the
political structure
i wanted you to be able to tell me a
year and i'll tell you who the major
nations in the world were at that time
and what was happening in africa at that
time
i wanted to stay in african religions i
wanted to understand everything right
and so historically i'm a huge history
buff all the way back to the big bang
and so what happened is i realized you
know okay i'm doing well in school
stuff like this matters i feel like i've
become a new person i've let go the old
guy you know i'm now the the man
and i was reborn in a way so i said
here's what i want
i want my middle name to express who i
am i want my first name to express who i
am who i wish to become and i want my
last name to honor
my african ancestors and the reason
that's why i identified with right
and so my middle name muata is swahili
and it means he seeks the truth
my first name hakeem most people know it
from the muslim connotation
but actually it's all over the easter
near east and africa
and it always means the same thing some
form of wise
and my last name oh luchay means god has
done this i want it
it's yoruba because on my mother's side
of the family
our uh you know we have family
gatherings they were proud of always
saying we were not slaves we were not
slaves
and frankly until the actual research
was done and put in my face in the 90s
i'd never believed that i was like then
how the hell did we get here then
we're black right um but it was true
uh and so uh my ancestors
this no it was the black settlers it was
the black settlers that came across the
bering strait
they went from the lost tribe of the
bearing strike
well you know i did you know you read
roger what's his name roger a somebody
who's like everybody in history was
black this guy was black that guy was
black right
beethoven's black so um
what was i saying so so uh oh shade
they came from he came from europa land
went to france
went to san to domingo had a son my
great-grand
great great grandfather and then moved
to uh new orleans
where so this is my great great great
grandfather
and my mother's great-great-grandfather
right yeah that's it all right so this
is
your balloon rebirth here absolutely
this is this this isn't so you are a
person you changed your name because
when you went to stanford
and your book none of the white people
would help you
with your projects and you after you had
helped them
and so you like you know what i'm gonna
make these people as uncomfortable as
possible
yeah my name is hakeem now okay
no it wasn't that that was i did do that
my early years i wasn't one of the few
research groups that had a stereo
in there and they were known for that
being so cool they have a stereo in the
student offices
dude one day i went down there i put on
chuck d america's most
follow excuse me not chuck b ice cube
america's most followed by ice cube
kill at will follow my ice cube death
certificate
but later i learned that we are all
medically sent
back to jail at that point but you know
i learned that we're all individuals so
i don't even say white people black
people like that anymore
because you know i'll tell people i'm
lucky i've been abused by white cops and
black cops i've been held at gunpoint by
black dogs and white thugs you know i
realize
that you know there is a identity
hierarchy in our country
right and one of the things that happens
is you leave america you have the sense
of
right because you don't feel it anymore
you don't feel that depression anymore
it's a weight lifted it's a it's a
fascinating phenomenon yeah i don't have
that i don't have that problem
i look down on everyone so
well you know one of the psychological
games i play like when i'm drawing
going across driving across the part of
the country where it's worse than others
is i pretend i'm in another country
because then i don't know what your
assumptions and thoughts are
right i don't know what your morays are
in your countries so i'm free
yeah but they'll let you know real fast
hey i'll tell you a funny story like
that what i was thinking
you ain't from around here now from
these parts
when i came back to astronomy i was at
uc berkeley
and among the group of people i was in
we saw a pearl mudder in those cats
and and what they you know my blackness
for the first time
wasn't this issue so i was sitting in a
talk and i was like
oh my god i forgot i was black right
then right right i left that position
and became a professor in northern
alabama and they were like oh no
no no no no you're black
wow so guys we got to land this plane so
let me uh
so so this this was quite the journey
like i said you you should write a book
oh you did write a book okay
that's right a quantum life my unlikely
journey from the streets to the stars
and it's published in the the random
house group right
uh who is it penguin rent but who's that
specific it's on the valentine imprint
on
the valentine imprint that's out this
year yeah yeah so
this sounds like a long overdue memoir
based on all the stuff you were talking
about
now i wonder you know if all this is
happening to you this is just your
memoir part one
because the rest of your life that's got
to be worth another memoir i'm thinking
oh it's absolutely it's even crazier i'm
not abused for the first half of it
you know it's because now i have agency
now i'm the guy
who can make a difference in other
people's lives right yeah so that'll be
how
all that got turned into something where
you do some good for the rest of the
world and for the frontier
the moving frontier of physics so uh i'm
liking it
dude thank you listen thanks for being a
guest on star talk
and will you invite us to the
uh the the hollywood premiere of the
biopic
on yeah because you know they're going
to make they got to make this into a
movie now
no i guess we haven't heard i guess you
haven't heard so we have not
oh so uh after i got the book deal i
went to hollywood i met with several
production companies
my last meeting was with a man named
chadwick boseman and his
partner logan coles um and
he took this on and
he when he passed away he had 10
projects and logan told me that my
our project together was the only one
where it wasn't resting on the fact that
he was
a um an actor in it he was purely
directing
and we met a week before he was giving
the commencement address at howard
and i was being awarded an honorary
doctorate at tougaloo
right and so we talked about this and he
championed my story
and universal signed it on the first
pitch and we signed a movie deal
two years ago wow already all right
so chadwick's death has changed things
yeah okay well don't worry because it's
a great story it's still good yeah
somebody will pick up somebody and
somebody will be this you should not
need chadwick
boseman to get made i'm pretty sure
about that and just make sure
michael b jordan plays you man because
then you know
it's guaranteed success yeah and i'll
just just so you know the similarity
between my childhood abs
and michael's current abs
[Music]
[Laughter]
i got six pack abs too they're just
under four inches of fat right they're
there i promise you
all right guys uh so listen uh thank you
hakeem
for agreeing to this interview and good
luck with the book tour
and you got good backing behind that of
random houses in the equation
so hope to see you on the best seller
list and uh well
and i'm waiting for my ticket to your
the premiere
and and uh chuck agreed that um
michael jordan's got to play play you
okay in this role so that'll happen
all right uh chuck always good to have
you here always a pleasure
this has been star talk radio an
exclusive interview with hakeem
oluseyi who is a fellow astrophysicist a
meeting really here for the first time
and who has a remarkable life captured
in his memoir
which comes out this june okay so uh
this has been star talk i've been neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist
as always keep looking up
[Music]
you